hello everyone welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1914
tournament of sang Peter Berg and
capablanca faces a world champion
Emanuel a spur for the third time in his
life first time in the 1914 tournament
of son Peter Berg second time also here
in the second part of the tournament
both games ended in a draw
even though Kobe Lanka was better he was
really a much better in the first game
in the second game he was better but not
really sure how he could have a gun for
something more than a draw and here
again he has a chance with the black
pieces let's see how he does and
capablanca is having we could say a
perfect tournament so far keeping in
mind that this is one of the strongest
tournaments ever held also as you can
see world's champion also attending
without a single loss so far kappa
blanka alaska only one loss in the
beginning of the tournament but here in
the second part of the tournament we
already mentioned five of the players
are continuing the second leg of the
tournament they are going into a double
round-robin and the Capablanca went into
the second part of the tournament being
a point and a half in the lead so that
goes into the second part of the
tournament as well so capablanca has a
huge advantage here but Emanuel Lasker
he's having an excellent second part of
the tournament so Capablanca before
facing Glasgow here for the third time
in the second part of the tournament two
wins and two draws and Lasker three wins
and one draw so he managed to lower the
lead of one cattle Oscar by one point so
here crow also has a great opportunity
to equalize with with Capablanca and
also I would just like to mention that
is the first of the month so do check
out that YouTube has not unsubscribed
you against your will as you know this
is you might be just watching and never
commenting and then YouTube might get
the idea that you are an inactive
subscriber and then YouTube will
unsubscribe you against your will you
know YouTube's algorithms work in
mysterious ways but just in case you
know do check and also we are not going
to have a third game between Alaska and
capablanca without some epic music so
first thing you will see in the
description below a link to some epic
music do check it out to get in the mood
for this game sorry about that
Alaska has the white pieces and he opens
with
for now of course couple mark already
challenged Lasker once after he is a
nineteen nineteen eleven son Sebastiaan
victory and of course he studied last
girls games he even published some of
the games from the natural ice crush
lighter in Hindi magazine couple Lanka
was a chief editor of so not something
last weekend really surprised capablanca
with so it's very interesting what the
last group will choose here with E 5 and
night to have three nights the c6 and
now Bishop to b5 high school goes for
the real Lopez we have a six more fees
defense by capablanca Bishop captures D
captures and now d4 and it's very
interesting
Blanca even mentioned about this line
for white that it doesn't really give
white anything giving up the bishop pair
so early that it should only favor black
he captures we have Queen captures last
were already a mu six offers the Queen
and well it's not really we can't really
call it an endgame right away since
there are so many pieces on the board
but capablanca but last we're playing
couple Blancas game against Capablanca
so Queen captures Knight captures and
now the most standard idea today would
be Bishop to d7 but then a cup of vodka
went for Bishop to d6 and okay we have
Knight to c3 now you were fighting for
the e5 square if you go something like
f4 then f6 is an idea still nothing to
be worried about here with black so
instead night the c3 battle Oscar at
night the e7 by capablanca and now both
players Castle now we have f4 by Lasker
and now rook to e8 cover one cannot
worried about any five ideas and here
Knight to b3 and this is only move 11
but it's interesting after this last
Chris Knight to b3 move this position
has never again been repeated in you
know in in tournament chess or the
disposition is only available in the
database via this game so f6 by
Capablanca we have now f5 limiting the
mobility of Capablanca bishop and also
preparing bishop to afford to trade the
dark square bishop sand last course plan
is to leave Capablanca with the bad
bishop here so b6 cup of Wonka's idea is
the
the light-square bishop via bishop to b7
then pushed c5 and this will make the
light square bishop come alive bishop to
a4 by Alaska and here the idea that come
oncome mist that will well that the most
likely haunted him for a very long time
is that she should have gone for Bishop
captures and only after Luke captures
place c5 which then allows him to
develop the light square bishop very
nicely and also more importantly he
would take away the d4 square from
Alaska is night but here kappa blanka
when the bishop to b7 immediately
seemingly it has no difference but it
does the difference is huge here at last
replaced Bishop captures we have C
captures and now Knight to d4 brushing
and pressuring the seeks exponent but
also threatening Knight the e6 and here
is the one of those moments when you
play a chess game where you don't want
to admit that your Bishop to b7 move
wasn't all that impressive where you
should go back simply Bishop to c8 cover
that square and only then kick the
knight back with c5 but here Kabam Anka
continues the game pretending like
Bishop to b7 was was an all right move
we have rook 8e egg my kappa blanka and
now Knight to e6 by Lasker an excellent
outpost for the night attacking the rook
here rook to d7 and now rook a to D 1
and here d6 is a very weak pawn now at
the d5 square very nicely controlled by
Alaska Alaska will most likely either
double rooks by Roku D and then rook
here or rook F rook F 2 to D 2 and we'll
go after the weak d6 pawn so kappa
blanka needs to do something about this
with Knight to c8 now the knight is
defending the d6 pawn so there will be
no problems here and also the rook is
controlling the g7 point so no rook
lifting ideas are possible here by
Lasker we have looked to f2 preparing to
double up on the D file b5 by capablanca
and now rook F to D 2 going after this
pawn which is not defended by the knight
but now the knight really doesn't have
all that much activity we have rook data
east 7 now and now before taking away
all DF of NC 5 moves from Capablanca and
King to f7 with a 3 by Lasker and now
bishop to a a to making room for this
rook to come to a seven kappa blanka
will look for some activity via da five
move with King to f2 Lasker starts
improving the position of the King rook
to a7 and now
g4 with h6 by capablanca now comes Luke
to d3 and now a five busting open here
on the Queen side h4 bail ask her a
capture son be for a capture son before
and now the rook who goes back as it
there's really not all that much to do
on the Queen side with King to f3 last
but keeps improving the position of his
King and now rook to GA preparing g6 we
have King to f4 Alaska winning more
space with the king and now g6 of course
you cannot capture as the knight would
hang here so we have looked to g3 battle
Oscar here there is an interesting
engine line for Alaska but it's a very
very long and complicated line that
starts with the g5 but it's a it's a
very nice line so we'll just show it
just you know to see that it's actually
there after g5 now there's the threat of
Luke coming over here and then you will
capture on g6 and then force a
discovered check so why black would have
to deal with this H captures H captures
and after root 2 H it now comes rook to
g3 with the idea of pawn captures not
immediately as the night is still
undefended F captures on g5 with Czech
rook captures and g5 now threatening to
capture here and bring the other roof to
g1 and after Luke to h6 now you would
have looked to a-1 preparing to win the
bishop here Luke a7 blocking now Knight
to d8 check king to have six and now
rook captures on a 7 Knight captures and
here after F captures on g6 rook
captures on g6 rook air-five check King
to e7 and now you would get a rope to f7
check and after captures captures it
would seem the dark square bishop is
lost
that's what optimal play from both sides
but it's a it's a really exhausting
engine line I just wanted to point it
out that it in fact was there but okay
our last pair first prepares g5 with
rook to g3 and now Capablanca doesn't
want a square to push g5 so he pushes g5
himself we have King back to f3 getting
out of check
not nice to be six if you capture here
just rook to h3 white does not have a
problem here so nice to be six and now H
captures on g5h capture son g5 and rook
to h3 now winning the H file preparing
to do this very nice rook lift rook to
d7 making some room for the king to be
able to move around and now King to g3
also possible is rook to h7 check and
after the King moves not rook to h6 will
be very strong where the king will have
to go back to defend and now white will
just drastically improve the position of
the rook but lasker goes for roof King
to g3 with King t8 and now comes Luke D
to H 1 with completely winning the H
file we have Bishop to b7 kappa blanka
the bishop still locked in not not a lot
to do with the light square bishop and
now a beautiful move by Alaska which
really brings a lot of activity into the
game the knight on c3 is not one would
say optimally placed but it prevents
black from ever pushing c5 due to the b5
pawn being lost but here at last replace
be five and now the night is coming into
the game via the square e 4 so there's
not all that much to do here you have to
either capture or push c5 if you push C
5 then roof to h8 is very strong here
you give up the rook on h1 for the rook
and g8 and after Bishop captures rook
captures with check King g7 now you go
he captures on f6 King captures and B
captures on c5 after D captures Knight
captures here now attacking the rook and
also look to g6 is a threat where you
could win the night here so after black
prevents this or Knight g5 also is
playable rook to g6 would be a threat
once again after the King moves and now
we pick up another pawn and now you just
end up in this end game where white is
winning being up to 2 connected passed
pawns
so after this if I move Capablanca
decides D captures on e5 it doesn't
matter if he decided to capture with the
F pawn the e4 square is still freed for
Lasker's night so tonight the e4 and
here Knight captures on f6 is a threat
but with the double forks so couple unka
has the defendant Knights that
five defending the f6 pawn but now night
six comes the c5
there you have it attacking the bishop
and the rook and it's interesting
Alaska waited until Capablanca plays
this waiting move Bishop to b7 to push a
five so the this night landing on c5
would come with an attack on the bishop
here so the bishop is under attack the
rook is under attack if you move the
rook let's say rock c7 you can either
capture and then go Knight d6 check or
just 96 check now comes with a double
attack against the bishop on b7 wins the
piece after the King moves less the King
f8 now you just win it the knight
defense night
so after Knights the c5 capablanca
played Bishop to see it but there was no
there was no good way of saving the rook
or any way for that matter
Lasker captures the rook we have Bishop
captures and now loop to h7 and it's not
just that last chorus of the exchange
okay couple blanca is up upon so maybe
if the bishop could come alive maybe
there could be some counter play but
it's just still a very very bad Bishop
rook to a fade by kappa blanka and now
rook to a1 threatening some checkmating
radius would rook to e8 we have King to
d8 by capablanca and now rook to e8
trick Bushra blocks with c8 and here
Alaska just played Knight the c5 and it
was in this position that josé raúl
capablanca
resigned in the game this is his first
loss in the 1914 tournament of sank
Peter Berg and his first loss ever
against World Chess Champion Emmanuel
ask her definitely a tough blow for
Capablanca who was having the perfect
tournament without a single loss so far
but here now with a loss against him and
Alaska and as we already mentioned that
last girl lowered the lead of Capablanca
from the first part of the tournament to
only one point here with this win Alaska
equalized and this is a huge
psychological victory for Lasker who who
went into the second part of the
tournament being down a point and a half
and it will be well I can only imagine
that it was very very stressful but we
will mention some details from from
Kappa Blancas book about this event and
death and about the games that follow
but Alaska I mentioned that you know the
few people that were watching
the game as it was unfolding into this
beautiful finish
you know after kappa blanka knock down
his king there was this huge applause
and everyone was just you know thrilled
about the game to mention why did he
resigned there's no move black can make
whatever move you make there's there's
no good move to show what you could do
but let's say any move then brush up a
spin you just gonna be seven checkmate
or you can even choose rook to d7
checkmate the bishop is still pinned so
there's really no no way to to avoid all
of the threats so that's the game i do
hope you enjoyed it and it's very
interesting if we go back just a little
bit to this Bishop to a4 idea work up
one cut played Bishop to b7 - up to b7
proved to be at the decisive mistake
that allowed last card is much activity
just Bishop captures rook captures and
c5 prevents the knight from ever coming
to d4 and taking this beautiful outpost
on e6 Capablanca would just develop and
the game continues but this is not this
is not the main point of the game the
main point of the game is that last card
was able to in a in a tournament where
he's a whole point against behind josé
raúl capablanca he needed to catch up to
him he needed to beat him and how do you
beat him you don't want to go into any
complications that arise from the
Queen's Gambit the client or from the
tower defense so how do you do it you go
into this positional opening that
capablanca himself already said that
didn't really give anything for white
you give couple lunk at the bishop pair
early on and there kappa blanka has a
position where he's the one who should
be looking for advantage but coupling
obviously felt too safe in the position
he was already leading a full point in
the tournament and you know it's like
class were hypnotised Capablanca and
allowed for this beautiful victory to be
to be you know achieved it's it's just
amazing how how loss of Lasker
accomplished such a feat I mean it's
really really remarkable but yeah as I
said after we show there are three more
games
Capablanca played in this tournament so
then we're gonna go over some details
and we're gonna go back to this moment
and so on and so on so make sure to
follow the
the saga until the end yeah once again
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank very much Murdoch
John Edwardson Kevin strange den den
Ponton and Michael Henrik for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to on my previous videos Sarah
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content we'll be checking up
on what's happening in the world and of
course continuing the capablanca saga so
thank you all and I will see you soon
I have an excellent rest of your Friday